think sharks are scary
well this monster fish can eat a shark
in a single gulp
oh my god
weighing as much as a grand piano
this territorial giant makes headlines
when it's hungry
amateur videos show goliath grouper
aggressively eating anything and
everything
floating on the surface and craziest of
all
attacking scuba divers
[Music]
once fished to near extinction these
protected ocean giants
are reclaiming their home turf
[Music]
so i'm in florida to catch a super-sized
goliath grouper
and see if it really is the monster it's
made out to be
my god
[Music]
known internationally as a fishing and
dive capital of the world
people here in florida love to play in
and around the water
but some people think there's a
potential monster-sized problem
lurking beneath the surface and it's not
a shark
by the mid-1990s goliath grouper were so
overfished
they became listed as critically
endangered
so under current u.s law it's illegal to
handle or remove one from the water
so to see how these giants really behave
i'm going to need to call in the experts
i'm out with chris malinowski and a
research team from florida state
university
very little is known about these
sumo-sized fish
so chris is trying to learn where they
live what they eat
and whether or not this protected giant
is actually making a comeback
not only is his research crucial for
their future survival
but it's the only way i can legally
examine one
i don't see any fishing rods on board
how are we going to catch these fish
the easiest way that we've found to
catch them is actually through using
a hand line it's basically a rope we're
going to be catching grouper with a hand
line
this is big heavy-duty gear a thick rope
900 pound monofilament line and then
pretty much the largest circle hook you
can buy how big that hook is
want to be able to out muscle the
grouper as soon as i feel a bite i'm
going to get into a tug of war with the
grouper and i'm trying to get it up to
the surface
is there a chance we'll catch fish other
than grouper there's a lot of
different shark species in this area
that we end up pulling up some of them
pretty big some big and we caught
14 foot hammerhead during our last trip
so these are massive fish wow
sharks are a whole different game
when they get to the surface
unlike goliath grouper sharks will use
their jaw
their sharp teeth they'll swing their
head and bite down
so if we catch one we'll only want to
bring it halfway into the boat to unhook
it
before releasing it back into the ocean
what bait are we going to use so we're
going to start off with a huge chunk of
bonita here
okay so it's very important when you're
doing this because we're catching such
large fish you've always got to watch
your feet
because if a fish are a shark grabs
it'll take you right into the water okay
just chuck it overboard all right and
then hold on to that mono
keeping that in front of you good
[Music]
if that float starts bobbing or it goes
underneath the water
that's an indication that i have a big
fish
but i have no way of knowing if i've
hooked a shark
or a goliath grouper i just know that
it's gonna be a big fight
oh there we go got one [ __ ]
coming toward the boat hand over hand
if it's a grouper it's going to be a
monster oh here we go
shaking shake it
it's coming up you can feel the tug
shaking
oh i see white it's shark it's spinning
see the huge dorsal fin on the back
that's characteristic of the sandbar
shark
uh make another run
we're gonna try to get this into the
boat head first
[Music]
okay oh that's enough that's enough
that's enough yeah okay guys
right that's a big probably seven eight
feet long
you can see the big dorsal fin big peck
pins
watch yeah out in the face that was fun
and these sharks they can twist they'll
throw off their head
you can see if it senses something close
to it it'll bite down so right there
it's kind of blocked it can't really
move its head too much and twist around
for a bite so this is the safest place
to
keep this shark got a tag
we're going to clip the hook so that it
doesn't have it's hook and a shot
anymore
okay it's ready to go all right
nice
good work guys that's good
that really was a monster of the deep
but i want to know if the goliath
groupers bite is just as big
so it's time to fade up and cast out
[Music]
oh fish oh god it feels like we hooked
onto an anchor
go around the other side
it's a large shark big dusky it's hard
to maneuver
it's probably eight or nine feet long
here it is we got big tail rope nice you
got it
let's go okay we got a tail so now we
can control it a little bit easier
and we're gonna bring it in tail first
into the boat it's a really beautiful
shark watch out
[Music]
oh my god
now cut the hook out
oh man
that's a big fish
[Music]
sharks are clearly an apex predator out
here
they're so quick to our bait we're gonna
need to drop more hooks to increase our
chances of catching a goliath grouper
oh man fish really heavy
it's hard to hold on to it that really
is like tug of war isn't it
feel free to help me three people
three of us goliath grouper can weigh as
much
as a grizzly bear and right now that's
what this fish feels like
i think we got it ugh just keep pulling
keep keep pulling
just watching keep going keep going keep
going
remember to watch your hand from the
leader part yeah
oh man it feels heavy glass grouper
big one yeah it looks big
we're gonna get it on board here it
comes
nice nice man big fish
so first goliath grouper big man's
massive
towel over the head of the fish to keep
it calm a tube in the fish's mouth to
pass water over its gills
and we're going to strap it down so in
case it starts flapping
it stays secured to this stretcher
check it out our first grouper man it's
a big fish
they're one of the largest bony fish on
earth
grow up to about eight feet long over
600 pounds
everything about this fish is super size
you can see
big head large mouth thick lips
the dorsal spines are almost the size of
one of my fingers
and this kind of classic grouper mottled
color
lighter belly darker back
one of the most impressive things about
the glad grouper not necessarily the
length but its
mass the thickness all of the muscle the
strength and that's what i'm feeling
when i'm holding on to that hand line is
this fish
using its strength to try to get back
down to the ocean bottom
when you're ready pull tight and let me
know what number you got okay
one five three is that right yeah one
five three
awesome this is a five foot goliath
group for how much would you guess this
fish weighs probably around 200 pounds
that's a big fish yeah it's a big fish
amazingly this grouper could get four
times heavier
and weigh 800 pounds by the time it's
fully grown
chris wants to find out what the goliath
grouper is eating
and he's figured out a bizarre but
effective way to do just that with a
plastic pipe
the easiest way to get the stomach
contents is actually put my hand
and my arm all the way into the fish's
belly go all the way until you feel the
back of its stomach
all the way all the way in feel around
for anything that might be in there
it doesn't smell very good either feels
like i'm putting my hand into a roast or
like a
raw steak i can't tell what stomach and
what's bait
oh there's something in here yeah
that's gross
and partially digested fish parts we
will take it
all right so put that in here is our
stomach sample
so you can see here that's a crab part
right there you can also see
fairly small vertebrae which would be
from a smaller reef fish
probably not something very large i was
expecting to find large fish in the
stomach
the groupers normal diet it's not large
fish it's it's crabs
and smaller fish exactly behaviorally
they know they don't swim very fast so
they're not going to be after very fast
prey they often feed into the bottom
into the sediment
wow so even though the goliath grouper
is able to swallow
a big bait normally grouper feed
relatively low
on the food chain on crabs and small
fish
and that's an important clue this
goliath grouper wasn't searching the
ocean
looking for big prey like those sharks
were to hook this
grouper i had to drop my bait right in
front of it on the ocean bottom
okay you ready clamp it perfect hey
okay fish is tagged we ready to get this
fish back in the water ready to get it
back in the water then
[Music]
but before i can release this grouper
something big is hitting my other bait
fish on oh my god it's huge
we got a fish
just like pulling a sack of some men
isn't it oh
looks like a grouper seeing that pale
kind of yellow
oh i'm fighting the fish and the current
trying to get up behind the boat here
just gonna look at it
oh man i'd say that's maybe five and a
half feet long so we caught two fish
at the same time these guys say that
isn't unusual once we get
the first bite then other grouper can
sense
what's going on and they'll come in and
feed as well creating a feeding frenzy
so check out this now then what you can
see immediately it's not like
a shark with sharp jagged teeth
on the upper and lower jaw are
pads of needle-like teeth that are
pointed backwards so if i put
my finger in its mouth and try to pull
my finger out it grips so that's exactly
what would happen to
prey that ended up in a grouper's mouth
they can open their mouth very very
very wide the grouper will suck and pray
clamp down
and use those teeth to grip on to prey
and then swallow the prey hold
so this is an important clue groupers
are not biting and ripping apart prey
like a shark
they're sucking it in and swallowing it
whole which makes total sense
now that i know grouper eat mainly small
fish and crabs
hardly the diet of a ferocious monster
it's a recapture so this is a fish that
these guys have already caught and
tagged once
okay tag number nine 96f2508
got it what are the tags and recaptures
tell you about the fish's movement
patterns for recapturing this fish over
and over again that means that they're
likely residents because they have a
very strong sight fidelity they don't
move a lot during most time of the year
so that's an important clue goliath
grouper
aren't like sharks patrolling large
expanses of ocean
looking for prey they'll find a wreck or
reef they like
and make that their home done trapping
first
yeah i really thought the traps off this
is good
see you later wow
[Music]
working with chris and his research team
and catching two big
ocean predators i now know that goliath
grouper are misunderstood
even though goliath grouper are big
powerful predators
they're not feeding on the top of the
food chain they're not violently ripping
up prey with their teeth like some
sharks
they're sucking in prey with their mouth
and goliath grouper aren't out
patrolling the open ocean like those
sharks i caught
they're sticking to one chosen reefer
wreck if i need small prey on the ocean
bottom
so why are there viral videos showing
them attacking large prey on the surface
i leave chris and travel cross state to
the gulf of mexico
where some of these viral videos have
emerged
it's here in the small town of englewood
where local fishermen are going to help
me set the record straight
i want to see whether or not the viral
videos of goliath grouper
are true and if so figure out why a
bottom dwelling fish
is behaving so aggressively at the
surface
[Music]
i'm out with dan he's a florida local a
charter boat captain and he has
encounters with goliath cooper every day
this is something i'd like to see for
myself
we're about five six miles offshore here
fishing above an artificial reef
this is a popular fishing reef where dan
says goliath grouper come to the surface
to feed aggressively
oh got a nibble got something
fish on
oh lost the fish something big came in
and got it
yeah he probably had about a three four
pound fish on there and then a glass
grouper came and got him about halfway
up so that's what people are complaining
about people come out here
try to catch smaller fish glyph grouper
come up whack
so i've witnessed firsthand a grouper
steal a fish
off my line and i know there is some
truth to those stories i heard
so how do you avoid that dan well the
best trick is when you feel that bite
you just reel
as quick as you can to try and get that
fish away from the bottom
and so as soon as the fish is hooked
it's a race because there's probably a
big grouper chaser you hit it right on
the head
[Music]
get them up get them up trying to get
them up as fast as i can
so it's a race now between me and the
grouper
come on go go go go get them out the
bottom
as long as i reel in fast get the fish
up to the boat as quickly as possible
no problems it's that extra two seconds
that that fish either has to rest or to
swim back down
that's all it takes your goliaths are
going to get them most of the time
the viral videos make a lot more sense
to me now
people are going out to locations that
have a lot of goliath grouper
they're putting bait in the water or
they have a weakened fish on the line
and the goliath grouper are coming in
for an easy meal
oh my god
so even though they catch the majority
of their diet on the ocean bottom
it's clear goliath grouper will still
target a big meal
if it's dangled in front of them or it's
on the surface i want to see if this
easy meal theory
explains the attacks on scuba divers to
do that i'm going out with tom
mclaughlin
he's been fishing and diving for over 20
years
and has a secret spot where i can dive
with goliath grouper
so where are we headed right now we're
headed to a big wreck in about 100 feet
of water it's the kind of place they
really like to live
the entire wreck is about 500 feet long
it's all broken apart
we're gonna focus in on one piece of
that wreck where tom says the grouper
really like to hang out
this is my first dive we're in about 100
feet of water diving on a wreck where
tom's seen a lot of groupers
he's also seen a lot of big sharks
around here so i'm excited feeling a
little bit nervous
just want to get in the water and get
down and see what's down there
[Music]
i love the water but that sense of not
being able to see
what's out there is still a little bit
unnerving
[Music]
out of the merc the gloom i see the
large
shape of a wreck emerge below me
and i need to be careful swimming in
confined spaces like this can be
dangerous
there are lots of things i can get
tangled up in
suddenly i look up and in front of is a
big shadow
moving in the darkness
and as my eyes adjust to the darkness
i'm face to face with the grouper
and i'm not sure how it's going to react
it seems to sense my presence and it
slowly
moves away i'm seeing
grouper poking their heads out of the
portholes in the wreck swimming up a
ledge peering over a crack and seeing a
grouper sitting down
in the hole of the wreck
none of the grouper being aggressive so
now i want to try the second half of my
experiment
and introduce an easy meal
we're sitting on top of the rack and a
big school of jacks
swims by us
the second tom spears that jack
the atmosphere on the wreck changes
the reef becomes more tense more turned
on more energized
as we're swimming up the wreck i see off
to my right something big coming out of
the darkness
it's not a grouper it's a bull shark
one of the most dangerous sharks in the
world
and it's coming right at us
i see this light shape coming towards me
pointed snout
sleek body more streamline than a
grouper
a seven foot bull shark it comes in
between tom and i
and circles back behind my head
this isn't a good situation a lot of
people get bitten by sharks in exactly
these circumstances
and it's circling us swimming around us
it's obviously
cued in on that bait as well
we need to get out of this situation
we move down to a crack in the wreck
where we'll be less
vulnerable to the bull shark
but the crack of the wreck is where all
the grouper are sitting
and the grouper are also behaving
differently because we have this fish
the grouper are being much more
aggressive moving more quickly
obviously interested in this fish that
we have
i pick up the fish hold it out and in an
instant a grouper comes in grabs the
whole head
of the fish of this jack in its mouth
pulls it from me and swims away
we can still see the bull shark
patrolling around the wreck
so we need to get back up to the surface
as quickly as we can
so it's clear that introducing food into
the equation
it triggers that grouper feeding
behavior
so now i can see that video in a
different way when that grouper
but it looks like it's attacking the
diver it's actually just going after the
food that that diver has
that's a clue that these grouper may not
be the monsters that some people make
them out to be
they're not searching out big prey or
treating humans as
food they're detecting small or injured
fish
using their lateral line like most other
fish species
i've yet to catch a fully grown goliath
grouper
but i've learned these fish only inhabit
certain structures and rarely move
so i'm going to need tom's help to find
a giant
he's one of the only people on the west
coast who's permitted to catch and land
goliath grouper for research
so he knows all the local grouper
hangouts
this is my opportunity to try and catch
the biggest client group i can find
and collect data for local scientists
along the way before we're able to catch
our grouper we need to catch
our bait there are a bunch of birds
right out here in front of the boat and
i can see action on the surface of the
water
if we can get right in the middle of the
school get some bait
oh yeah you can see them on the surface
here they're right behind the boat
[Music]
just moving my rod back and forth a
little bit to give that tube just a
little bit of action make it look a
little bit more like
a live fish
they're coming we're gonna get a bite
yeah i got one
oh he's running got a fish
hey and that's just our bait yeah that's
the bait he just took like 50 yards
alive
nice this is good bait this is a great
bait grouper just eat that thing no
problem they definitely would eat that
hole even
much bigger fish than this they'll get
full barracuda can get up to about
six feet long at this size at about
three three and a half feet
that's an impressive fish long slender
pointed nose relatively large eyes and
those very
sharp almost jagged teeth they have a
reputation
for being very efficient predators so
the fish that i'm after
could eat this barracuda in one bite
now that i've caught the bait i need
it's time to catch my monster-sized
grouper
where are we headed right now we're
gonna go over to the phosphate dock it's
an abandoned dock right on both the
grand pass
so this is kind of a local spot that's
known to have some big fish
there are a lot of records of catching
fish in the four and 500 pound range
we're fishing for a four or five hundred
pound fish
essentially in people's backyards
the grouper they're actually in between
those pilings their heads pointed out
and we're going to try to back the boat
in i'm going to drop the bait down as
soon as i feel the bite
i'm going to reel in tom's going to
drive the boat away from those pilings
and see if we can land a fish
ready yep drop it yup drop it
so i want to keep the bait about two or
three feet off the bottom
just keep the bait real still so we can
see when we get a bite
okay i'm on the bottom there reeled up a
little bit
just wait for that rod tip to bend
oh bite got one got one
oh no no
man so they're down there they're able
to move back into those pilings
and i can't hook them
on the bottom reel up a little bit
getting there's something
gotta hit your bite yep reel reel
all right yeah got one fish shot
holy
on got something here it's back behind
the boat
let's pull in line strong
shaking its head making another
and pushing back down towards the depths
we're gonna try to get this fish
away from the pilings
he's coming up coming up
the grouper look at him shaking his head
back and forth
wow nice fish
look at that tom's gonna drive the boat
over to the beach
we're gonna park quickly so tom and i
can tag and release this fish
okay we have the grouper to shore we're
gonna put it in this net
get a closer look
this is the first time i've seen a
juvenile glad
grouper so by comparison this is a small
guy
so how can you tell this is a juvenile
so it's partly the coloration it's
modeling
so do you think that as young fish this
modeling is almost a camouflage
absolutely this fish here spent the last
several years growing up in the
mangroves an estuary somewhere safe
starting to maybe now get a little bit
more bold venturing into deeper water
four feet two inches and now we want to
get a tag
it's tagged tag number five seven five
four this isn't my big grouper but it's
a big clue
catching a juvenile and not a giant is a
sign
that fully grown adults might have left
this location
and started their annual migration
offshore to spawn
and so the best chance for a really big
fish is
offshore most of those big fish they're
going to be offshore spawning right now
we're just going to hold him upright
he's swimming you can see the tail
moving
he's ready to go
awesome
[Music]
tom thinks that the giant grouper might
be spawning offshore
and when groupers do that they aggregate
forming large clusters to breed
so my timing could be perfect if i can
locate
where these fish spawn i could find not
one
but a whole bunch of monster size
grouper and there's one place
tom wants to check first so where are we
headed right now
here's our boat right here we're headed
towards the wreck
it's a giant freighter that's sunk it's
upside down kind of broken apart
full of holes so we're in 95 feet of
water right now so you can see
this line here at the bottom this blip
right below us
is the wreck and then a big school of
fish hanging out above the rack
this big school of fish might be the
aggregation of giants we're looking for
but there's only one way i can know for
sure
i drop it in the water and the clarity
is not good there's a strong
current
[Music]
i'm swimming along looking in portholes
no grouper looking into cracks no
grouper
maybe this was a false alarm maybe there
aren't any fish down here
[Music]
and then as i come around the front of
the boat
all of these grouper just appear before
me
6 10 15 just stretching out
as far as i can see in the distance
they're the size of small cars
i'm swimming right into the middle of a
huge aggregation
of one of the largest fish on earth
you only see something like this a few
places in the world
and here they are all of these goliath
grouper right in front of me
ready to spawn with the new moon
[Music]
man that was one of the coolest things
i've ever seen nothing could
really prepare me for seeing all of them
together like that
15 giant grouper all together
i've struck gold now that i've found
where the true giants are hiding
it's time to catch one
yep as fast as you can there you go
this is running towards the wreck we
caught this fish hooked this fish about
30 feet above the bottom
and he's running back down to the bottom
and i don't want him to get snagged on
anything
[Music]
taking his third run
he's pulling the boat moving the boat
over the wreck making dives
but i got some line on him now trying to
make another run
just had a huge run so
with this rod and this reel anytime i
can reel i'm reeling
unless the fish is running
oh my arm is running here we got here oh
there we go
i see something down there a silhouette
yeah it looks big whatever it is
that's a grouper cliff grouper he's
right out here in front of the boat uh
he's coming up to the surface
nice big fish beautiful color
this one's a little bit bigger probably
five and a half feet long
beautiful brown model color so you can
see this technique the big rod it worked
in about
60 seconds
okay you ready one two three
hold on
that's a big fish man nice
now that we've got it on board we need
to tag it and record the size and weight
for tom's research team
man the technique works deep water
fishing on a wreck
big bait and the biggest goliath grouper
yet so we're gonna just keep him
nice and wet here and then put this
saltwater hose across his gills and
that's gonna allow him to breathe while
he's in the boat
so we're on a clock right now five
minutes get the tagging done get a
length get a weight
and get this fish back in the water five
feet four inches
five feet four inches so almost as long
as i am tall
i'm guessing probably 120 pounds and
believe it or not they get a lot
bigger than this one we got a length we
got the tag
time to get this fish back in the water
yep
hang on that was the biggest goliath
grouper i've seen so far
but we're not catching any true monsters
where are the seven
and eight foot grouper
i want to try increasing the size of my
bait so first i'm gonna have to catch
some bigger bait fish
there's a school right in front of us
hundreds of fish just splashing on the
surface
oh look at that bull shark a little
shark
another bull shark
[Music]
fish on uh there's two sharks right
behind the boat
i'm gonna try to get this fish in before
the sharks come up
oh oh
there are two big bull sharks circling
right below the boat though
and they'll come up and take these
bonita right off the line
just trying to bring it up to the
surface as fast as i can
we can get three or four of these bonita
we have a good chance at a big grouper
[Music]
powerful fish it's a bait fish but it's
a good-sized fish
it's like maybe a two or three footer oh
i've beaten the bull sharks to my bait
nice beautiful this is the perfect size
to catch a massive grouper little bonita
looks like a little tuna
and they swim like a tuna two real
powerful burst of speed
believe it or not a goliath grouper can
swallow this
hole cool okay let's get it in the bait
box
we keep fishing until we have six or
seven bonita
you got one yep
oh my god there he is two fish on
[Music]
yep perfect bait size
this is the bait that we need to go
after a really big fish
oh no no no no
that didn't take long and as soon as
that bait in the water something bites
it
and this is something bigger
it's almost impossible to pull line off
this reel and this fish is doing it
it's bending the rod down into the water
this feels like a larger fish
this is the biggest fish i've had so far
so i need to remember everything i've
learned
oh come on come on come on come on come
on come on
grab the lions
just pull a lot of line this fish has
pulled more line
[Music]
it's hard to get any line on him
he's really swimming oh this could be a
big fish
run into that it's hard reeling in
feels big this could be it
this could be the fish
as fast as i'm reeling in the fish is
pulling line back out
the boat is being pulled from side to
side
this is a 32 foot 18 000 pound
boat that's being pulled by a fish
getting it now it's coming up coming up
this is the big one this is it i've done
it
it's amazing it's the fish i've been
looking for
a monster-sized grouper but it's so big
it's gonna be impossible for tom and i
to lift this fish into the boat
so i'm gonna get a length tag it and
release it in the water
[Music]
took all the strength i had tricks i've
learned
tom's help to get this thing up to the
surface
now that i'm in the water with this fish
i can see
just how big it really is seven feet
long
about 300 pounds just massive it's
longer than i am tall
the girth of it i probably couldn't put
my arms around it
the spines are almost as long and as
thick as my fingers
check out the size of its tail this is a
big
big fish i mean a lot of people say
these groupers very aggressive
but been in the water with it i can see
it for what it is
they're not being aggressive they're not
trying to attack people it's just
sitting there calmly no danger to me
whatsoever
so what i've learned is that the
majority of their food they're finding
on the bottom
in a small localized territory and
they're more curious
than they are aggressive when it comes
to humans and they're only coming to the
surface
where people are fishing to get an easy
meal
even the biggest of these fish are not
the menace or the monster that they're
sometimes made out to be
this is recovered it's ready to go
just gonna take it out away from the
boat give it a push down
it's gonna be gone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you